e
the house will attend to a Prayer by the
member from exor representative Alexis
Simpson
thank
everyone source of love and for giving
us the opportunity to be together one
last time this
bium in the midst of the devastation and
heartbreak of GL global conflict and
natural disasters you have given us an
opportunity to connect with one another
remind us that even in the midst of the
chaos of political campaigning it is the
human connection here that is most
valuable the relationships that drive
this work that allow us to negotiate to
compromise and to come together to serve
the greater good let us never forget
that there are people who care about us
as we mourn the loss of Fish and Game
conservation officer Levi Fry let us
remember that life is a struggle for
many people may you surround his family
and the families of all those who mourn
with your love and your care please show
us how we can continue to show up for
one another and offer help in all the
ways that we are
able in the words of St Francis oh God
make us instruments of your peace where
there is hatred let us so love where
there is offense let us bring pardon
where there is Discord let us bring
Union where there is error let us let us
bring Truth where there is doubt let us
bring Faith where there is despair let
us bring hope where there is Darkness
let us bring your light where there is
sadness let us bring
joy oh Lord grant that we may not so
much seek to be consoled as to console
to be understood as to understand to be
loved as to love for it is in giving
that one receives it is in self
forgetting that one finds it is in
forgiving that one is Forgiven it is in
amen the chair recognizes a member from
stratum representing Zoe Manos who will
Allegiance the United States of America
and
theice the chair now recognizes Chris
Eaton of stratum who will sing our
national
anthem can you
see by the da
early
light what so
proudly we
ha at the
Twilight last
ging who broad stripes and bright
stars Through the
perous
Fire or the ramp parts we
watch so
gly
streaming and the
rocket
GL the bombs
bursting
in gave prove through the
night that our flag was still
angled
W or the
land of the
free and the home of
[Applause]
[Music]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence Mr Speaker the day
illness Representatives fedus David
pagee Palmer rafter sanbor Gregory Smith
testerman Ward the day important
business representative ORS eel Edwards
Greg Griffin janisan
Carol Maguire Dan Maguire mle and Traer
the day illness in the family
McMahon these leaves of absent shall be
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
order the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Jared Eaton husband of the
singer and Mark Reen guests of
Representative Manos Jolene farmer and
Delany vogan guests of Representative
rat Lisa Vanda Castile sister of
Representative Vanda Castile Michael
Aaron husband of Representative Aaron
Denise Vose wife of Representative Vose
Dana albrech Tom Bloomquist Pam Brown
Scott Brer Pierre Dupont Linda Fran
Peter
kosi uh Janet Larson Rita McGrath Robert
Merill Jr Brian moris Ray Peoples Matt
pulin Jennifer Smith and Tim sweet here
guests of Representatives kutab and
[Applause]
house the house will now attend to
Communications Mr
Speaker in an email dated June 25th 2024
good afternoon Mr Speaker I hope your
summer is off to a good start I've been
honored to have served in the New
Hampshire House of Representatives for
this my second term the experience is
one I shall cherish forever I'm equally
grateful to have met in befriended C
several fellow Representatives not the
least of whom is you at this time I
submit to you my resignation from the
house effective July 1 2024 as I'm
preparing to move to another state in
order to pursue exciting new personal
and professional Endeavors thank you and
may God bless you sincerely Jeffrey gon
in a communication Del dated Friday July
5th dear Paul please accept this as
notification of my resignation for my
position of the New Hampshire house
effect of July 17th 2024 I understand
this disruption of this dis departure
and I sincerely apologize for any
inconvenience this may cause
unfortunately due to my moving from
marac to Florida I am no longer able to
serve the residents of marac in the
house I want to thank all staff and
members of the house for their guidance
and support during my two terms I also
especially want to thank the citizens of
marac for placing their trust in me to
represent them for the past four years
sincerely Robert V Healey in a
communication dated July 22nd speaker
Packard I regretfully resigned from the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
effective at 5: pm on July 31st 2024
I'll be moving out of state and thus
will not be able to serve my district
respectfully Sean
filio in a letter dated August 27th 2024
this is to tell everyone that I am
resigning from my position as a state
representative it has been rewarding
experience serving the state but my
health and has declined to the point
that I will check into Riverside rest
home tomorrow sincerely Cecilia rich in
a communication dated August 30th 2024
Mr clerk I have been proud to serve the
city of Manchester for the last two
years as one of its New Hampshire state
representatives so it is with great
gratitude and a little sorrow that I
must resign from this position my time
in the New Hampshire house has been both
an absolute pleasure and one of
difficulty thank you and your staff for
the grace and patience you have shown
over the last two years I look forward
to continuing to make New Hampshire a
New Hampshire for all best demon Ford
and in a letter dated September 11th
2024 Dear Mr Speaker and clerk it is
with great regret that I must resign my
office State Representative of chesher
County District 11 effective immediately
my privacy was invaded by the Winchester
town clerk in which he entered our gated
backyard and looked into several Windows
into our home we have purchased a home
in a surrounding town and will no longer
be residents of the town of Winchester
it has been a great honor to have served
my town and state thank you for the
incredible experience regards Zachary
Jan
nutting these resignations are accepted
with
regret the house will attend to an
enrolled Bill's Amendment Senate Bill
137 FN representative wasborn and
willhelm move the adoption of the
amendment the chair recognizes the clerk
thank you Mr Speaker ladies and
gentlemen the enrolled Bill amendment
process is one of clarification and
correction the enrolled Bill amendments
that are presented and prepared by the
office of legislative services are made
as technical corrections to bills as
they have passed however in this
instance for Senate Bill
137 it was a bill that was filed in the
first year of of the session and it was
a companion piece to another bill the
other Bill amended RSA
17913 which included uh an increase in a
fee uh from $100 to $250 and this was
passed and signed into law in the first
year of the session Senate Bill 137 was
re-referred for in for uh re-referred in
the senate in the first year which is
our version of retained and they acted
on it um at the beginning of this year
and sent it to Commerce the specific
provisions of the bill had ties into the
one that was signed into law last year
and because the the the other one was a
companion piece this one was not amended
in the proper sections of increasing
that same fee so the fee was still in
this bill as it passed this chamber $100
reflecting last year's uh initial bill
filing so OS drafted an enrolled Bill
amendment to up the fee to 250 to
reflect what is in current law as of
right now the uh Clerks of both Chambers
met with their respective leadership
teams and we felt that because this is a
substantive change rather than a
technical change that it was best uh to
have the house and the Senate vote on it
in full to reflect the will of the
bodies and that is why this amendment is
before you
now are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the RO Bill's
adopted we are moving on to the veto
messages
now the house will attend to the
governor's veto message on House Bill
194 FN requiring the director of the
division of historical resources to
compile and maintain a list of public
monuments and requiring legislative
approval the amendment or permanent
markers the question before the house is
notwithstanding the governor's veto
shall House Bill 194 refn become
Vil good morning and thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 194 was intended to
be a bill that simply put a
list of public monuments on the
dncr website so that historical
monuments can be visited by students
from across the country who compete on
this activity like Peak bagging is done
up in the White Mountains on the 484
th000 Footers um so this bill went
through our committee but when it went
over to the Senate there was an
amendment that we didn't
hear and that's where the problem lies
for us we believe that this is a house
matter and that the historic markers
program is really different than what we
were talking about we would like you to
have the opportunity to weigh on weigh
in on this um but we're asking you to
vote no please and that is because we
want to uphold hold the veto on the bill
um I just wanted to mention on a more
personal level that I was able to sit
next to somebody who's an archaeologist
who often interfaces with the state of
New Hampshire and the uh Department of
cultural natural
resources and she has a lot of
information about the historic marker
program that I would love for her to be
able to testify in front of us we could
have a robust
discussion um and she mentioned a couple
of things about the program program that
exists right now such as it already has
a small budget of its own for reviewing
these um matters and it's so it's not a
question of money so I believe and I
hope that you understand that this
robust discussion should take place
should the bill be filed again and um we
are happy to do that we want you to have
a chance and we want the public to have
a chance to come before the house thank
you vote no
vulo thank you Mr
Speaker since
1958 the state of New Hampshire has been
M marking sites of historical importance
through the New Hampshire historical
Highway marker
program as of today there are 291 such
markers they are new ones being adopted
as we
speak this bill doesn't change the
existing
process but it adds an additional
steps where which involve the which will
involve the legis ISL in any decision to
or permanently remove
ex existing any existing marker I repeat
existing markers not new
ones this action was brought on by
reports of a lack of transparency
transparency and public input in
situations where the reviews of an
existing marker for revision or
retirement was
requested the original Senate Amendment
proposed that an approval of the
revision or retirement of a marker be by
legislative action
only that seemed cumbersome so a
committee conference was convened to
come up with a
solution a lot of the discussion of the
conference committee determined uh
determined the review by the fiscal
committee would be simplest
and most effective the governor's veto
of hbb 194 focuses solely on the Senate
amendment to House Bill 194 which looks
to involve the legislature in any
decision to amend or permanently remove
any existing
marker yes there are separations of
power but the distribution of power is
not not
equal all the powers rest with the
people and we are the leg the
legislature represent them now I want to
take a minute to fill you in the members
of the committee or fill you in on the
members of the committee of
conference there are three there were
three Senate
conferees the Democrat Senator had
served six terms in the Senate and two
terms in the house
the first Republican
senator had served one term in the
Senate and three terms in the house once
as a as a
chair the second Republican senator has
served eight terms in the
house excuse me eight terms in the
Senate and four terms in the house and
is the Senate Majority
Leader the four house
conferees the first Republican House
member M served seven terms and as a
chair the second Republican House member
served nine terms and as a chair is a
chair the first Democrat House member
has served 13 terms and is a former
chair of finance and Judiciary and the
second Democrat House member has served
10 terms and the former minority leader
the former majority leader and former
speaker of and of the house and now
speaker
ameritus that's
126 years of legislative
experience that's a hell of a lot of
you the state constitution requires a
roll call a 2third vote is required to
override a veto this will be a roll call
the house will be in
order this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes rep of gerana for
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that uh I am the prime sponsor of the
bill that I am asking you all to sustain
a veto on uh and if I know that we owe a
debt of gratitude to our house
colleagues who served on the committee
of
conference if I know that the process of
responding to public concerns about how
our shared history is memorialized needs
to be worked on but if I know that the
bill as we have before us did not
receive the time and attention uh and
the debate that it should have had in
committee and if I know that the
interest of the public is not served by
subjecting this process to the partisan
political fights and Maneuvers which
would result from the amendment that was
attached to the original bill would I
now press the red button to sustain The
veto thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative vulo for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the ultimate
responsibility for protecting our
heritage should rest with the people's
Representatives
then would I vote to override The veto
green this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor of having the bill become law
you will press the green button if you
are opposed and wish to sustain the
governor's veto you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Terry while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
vote 132 voting a 195 voting a the
sustain the house will attend the
governor veto message on House Bill 274
relative to the administration
rulemaking process question before the
house is not withstanding the governor's
law chair recognizes Representative
Steven
Smith thank you Mr
Speaker this bill does a couple of
simple things and by the way we passed
it out of here
unanimously if a state agency or
Department goes before the joint
legislative
commit to propose a rule and they say no
a few times and the stakeholders
involved say no probably more than a few
times and then it gets challenged in
court and the court says yeah you you
can't you can't do this right now that's
just the end of it there's no
Consequence the governor's veto message
complains that we didn't give a fiscal
note on what these legal fees were going
to be I have a suggestion for the
executive branch when jail car says no
and the stakeholders say no stop it you
know how that's going to turn out don't
expect that there won't be a consequence
now today they can expect there won't be
a consequence but there isn't one but
I'm asking you to give them one it's
really simple um he complained that some
of the provisions are onerous when rules
are proposed they have to notify any
known stakeholders and the legislative
policy committee that's honorous that
isn't
it's necessary if they're going to get
policy right it is necessary for the
branches of government to talk to each
other I don't blame them it's making
their job a little harder I if I was the
governor I might have vetoed it too but
I'm not I'm a state representative and
my first job is to keep the power here
in the people's house where we are
closest to the people so please endorse
this new process and provide a
consequence for rules that are against
legislative intent and press the green
button
today the state constitution requires a
roll call a 2/3 voter is required to
override a veto this is a roll call vote
this is a roll all vote if you're in
favor of having the bill become law you
will press the green button if you
oppose your wish to sustain the
governor's vle you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
repr
all members president had an opportunity
vote 320 ver voting a five voting a the
overridden the house will attend to the
governor's veto message on how Bill 396
permitting classification of individuals
based on biological sex under certain
limited
h thank you Mr
Speaker HB 396 is a relatively short
Bill effectively it's one page worth of
legislation what it
does is it confines our discrimination
statutes and our policy in three
critical areas I want to highlight
section two and I want to read
it in athletic or sporting events or
competitions in a sport of similar
activity in which physical strength
speed or endurance is generally
recognized to give an advantage to
biological
males we have sports for
kids volleyball basketball
soccer in wrestling we we segregate it
by weight for a reason we know that
physical strength and and body mass
actually create a distinct Advantage so
we have weight classes but we don't do
that for ER we don't ask the the the
athletes to show up on the field and
step on a scale to know whether they can
wrestling we could segregate our
Sports by just creating co-ed and
allowing all the kids to play that
option exists for all the schools in the
state we haven't done that but that is a
a way to address the issue before
us we could ask that the the school
segregate it by by body
mass but we don't we segregate it by
biological
sex and we do that because we do know
that there are distinct
advantages for biological men relative
to
women boys versus girls on the
field two of my children are over
6'4 imagine my junior age High School
junior age son decid deciding he wanted
to be on the volleyball team or on the
basketball
team in the in the girls
room he would have a distinct advantage
height-wise over all the other
players that disenfranchises our young
girls in two major ways and for the
record he won't do that but my point
is it disenfranchises girls who want to
participate in these Sports who want a
scholarship to a college it also puts
them in grave danger of being hurt we've
seen this on the
field that's the reason we've created
girls soccer and boy soccer girls
basketball and boys basketball girls
volleyball and boys basketb B sorry
volleyball there is a reason we're doing
this is to protect the participants in
the sport I would ask that you would
thank
you a very wise grandfather gave me
these words about six months ago and
I've used them many times here in the
legislature you cannot provide equity
for 100% of the people 100% of the time
but you do have an obligation to protect
the safety of the
majority especially in sensitive
situations let us fulfill this
obligation to the majority thank
tour thank you Mr
Speaker in July Governor cunu vetoed
House Bill 396 and that was the right
decision let me start by reading from
the governor's veto message I quote
in 2018 Republicans and Democrats passed
legislation to prevent discrimination
because as I said at the time it is
unacceptable and runs contrary to New
Hampshire's livefree or die spirit that
still Rings true today the challenge
with House Bill 396 is that in some
cases it seeks to solve problems that
have not presented themselves in New
Hampshire and in doing so invites
unnecessary Discord
well said
Governor that 2018 Bill House Bill
1319 was entitled simply prohibiting
discrimination based on gender identity
and it did truly embody the states Live
Free or Die Spirit by
comparison House Bill 396 not only
undermines that Spirit but it does so in
the most dangerous and irresponsible
way House Bill 396 is an invasion of
privacy at its core
lacking any definition of the term
biological sex or how it would be
applied if this bill were to become
law somebody could simply look at an
individual trying to use a restroom and
tell them which bathroom they must use
based on their appearance the very
definition of
discrimination other options for
determining that person's biological
gender would be far more invasive still
I'll let you use your imagination
there it's it's also relevant to note
that a separate New Hampshire law pass
this session stemming from House Bill
1205 covers similar ground and currently
has our state embroiled in a federal
lawsuit that law requires that female
athletes and only female athletes must
show proof that they of their gender at
Birth when signing up for sports it has
been challenge for violating not for
upholding the provisions of Title 9 so
let's not for forc through another law
that will only lead to further confusion
Discord discrimination and litigation
when we have a clear statute preventing
these very things on our books Let's
vote to uphold the states Live Free or
Die Spirit by supporting the governor's
veto of this bill and voting no on the
override question thank you Mr
thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 396 came before the
Judiciary Committee almost two years ago
and I remember it well it was about a
three-hour hearing went 7 or 7:30 in the
evening and there were two people who
testified who really stood out to
me one of those was a transgender person
who was opposed to the bill
who
said we may be the people working in the
hospital who take care of you when
you're sick we may be the people in the
ambulance who pick you up and take you
there some of us are the people who are
clearing the road so that you can get to
school the message
and that struck me because my
have and yet that's that's how that bill
Framed I think that on many issues both
on the left and the right we are being
taught to believe that if we differ on
policy we must therefore hate each
other that is not
true it is an easy cell though because
power and it benefits people who are
pushing for Pure zero sum win
lose
outcomes it does not benefit those of us
who want to settle our differences
figure out a way that we can all live
together
outcomes sometimes wiwin situations are
very very hard to find sometimes it
seems
impossible but they're out there if we
look for them so there was a second
person who testified that stands out in
my mind she was a young mother from
Hampshire she told us that she was the
victim of sexual
assault that she's been in therapy for
years that she takes anti-depressants
and that she cries every day in the
shower all I want to do she said is to
protect my 12-year-old daughter her
12-year-old
daughter was a student in the Milford
school
system a 17-year-old boy in the Milford
system had taken to using
the bathrooms and locker
rooms including the girls locker room at
times the boy's locker room at
times would come in with his
friends and would make fun of this
12-year-old girl and her friends while
changed I don't know how we solv that
problem I don't believe that there is a
one-size fits-all solution to honoring
the people
who are opposed to the
bill and protecting that 12-year-old
girl in
Milford this bill is the best shot I
that the world is far more nuanced than
CNN or Fox News would have any of us
believe and if we allow other people to
write our narratives for you if we allow
other people
to completely validate one point of view
and completely invalidate the other
point of
view then we are destined to continue on
on we have seen what happens when the US
them Paradigm prevails in other
countries around the world and
throughout
history we have not reached Peak
intensity yet although I think a lot of
people think we have here in the United
to I have referred to House Bill 396 on
occasion as the can't we all get along
Bill I know others don't see it that
way but the question is how do we
navigate this new normal together in a
way that we can all live
with one size fits-all Solutions don't
work in a lot of cases
cases I don't imagine that my speech or
any of the other speeches here
today are going to change votes on this
veto
override but I think
our our nation and our world are in a
very dangerous
place especially as we approach an
upcoming election that has Global
consequences
we need to be able to step away
from the US them Paradigm from the this
or that black and
white
narrative and see each other as human
beings so I came up here not really
knowing whether this was going to
resonate I would ask my colleagues to
vote to
veto having said that
that if you don't override if you don't
vote to override The
veto vote your
conscience and
um if anything I've said resonates I ask
you that when you leave the chambers
today you take it out with you and back
you the state constitution requires a
roll call a two3 vote is required to
override a veto this will be a roll call
this is a roll all vote chair recognized
representative Divine for a
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that at its
core House Bill 396 sends the message
you are a freak what are you doing here
in a bathroom locker room or on a sports
team no matter how it support is dress
it up and and if I know the Milford
incident should have been a school
disciplinary issue or a crime that the
police should
handle then would I press the red button
in favor of sustaining the governor
Governor's veto of a misguided attempt
at regulation cutting through
decisiveness rhetoric masquerading as
concern for women's safety and just once
Mr Speaker I know you can recognize a
bad Bill I hope you'll vote with
us chair recognized representative kall
inquiry sen calt is waved
off this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor of having the buil become law
you will press the green button if
you're oppos and wish to sustain the
Govern is veto you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 164 voting day 168 voting May the
override
the house will attend to the governor's
veto message on House Bill 1093
prohibiting mandatory Mass policies in
schools chair recognizer
representative
Speaker Mr Speaker
last March this body voted to pass HB
1093 the bill prohibiting school boards
from mandating maske wearing the body on
the other side of this this wall did the
same soon
thereafter since that time there has
been some relevant new evidence that has
emerged to further support this bill on
May 31st the testimony that Anthony
fouchy had months ear earlier given to a
congressional subcommittee was finally
released when fouchi was asked by a
member of this committee if he had
followed any of the numerous scientific
studies concerning learning loss and
other negative effects on children
wearing masks fouchi
said
no he then
admitted there are a lot of conflicting
studies there are those that say yes
there is an impact and there are those
that say there's not I still think
air the doctor was further asked if
there was ever a cost-benefit analysis
done on the unintended consequences of
masking Kids versus the protection that
it would give them he answered not to my
knowledge during his testimony he also
admitted that the 6ot social dist
distancing sort of just appeared and was
not based on any scientific studies from
his other statements it seems likely
that mask mandates emerged in a similar
way his testimony asserts that there is
indeed a strong Reasonable Doubt
regarding the effectiveness of masks and
a growing concern for their possible
harmful
effects this shocking rev these shocking
Revelations seemed to have been
overlooked as HB 1093 was nevertheless
vetoed Dr fouchi the Doctor Who headed
one of the organization's recommending
masks had not even been following the
research being done on their effects on
children and then admitted that there is
no certainty that mask wearing did not
negatively impact
students during the co
pandemic we continuously heard the
phrase follow the
science the science as reflected in the
many conflicting studies that have
emerged does not provide clear
justification for mask mandates no one
especially a child should be forced to
do something that could possibly cause
him or her physical and even emotional
harm unless face mask are proven beyond
a shadow of a doubt to be harmless they
should not ever be mandated by school
boards in his veto message the governor
cited the importance of local control a
concept that usually makes sense in our
state school districts but this concept
of local control does not give School
boards the authority to make Health
decisions for students in in fact to do
so is unethical a recent article in The
Archives of disease and childhood
concluded that recommended child masking
is
unsupported by current scientific data
and inconsistent with accepted ethical
Norms decisions regarding the use of any
medical intervention should rightfully
be left to
parents to protect children from the
potential harm of maske wearing and to
recognize that the most fundament
fundamental unit of local control as the
family the governor's veto should be
overridden thank you Mr
Speaker HB 1093 would prohibit mandatory
mask policies in schools it would
eliminate the ability of local school
districts to put in place practices
procedures and policies to protect
students and staff in the event of any
health emergency regardless of guidance
provided by state or local Health
officials no one can predict what will
happen in the future best practices in
health disease and prevention continue
to evolve
based upon scientific
advances as the governor has noted we
have a responsibility to ensure the
state minimizes its infringement on
local
control our local elected school boards
should have the freedom to respond to
health emergencies according to the
individual needs of their Community to
best protect their children I urge you
to vote no no to suain the governor's
veto thank you chair recognized
representative
Noble thank you Mr
Speaker I rise today in support of
overriding the veto of HB
1093 The veto message states that just
because we don't like a local decision
doesn't mean that we should remove their
Authority
however in February of
22 the governor did remove local
Authority for mask
mandates as the public health guidance
had changed school districts were told
that they would be in violation of the
rules if they did not end their mask
mandates that's not local
control the state believed at least in
that moment that state public Public
Health experts were more qualified to
make the decision about mask
policies instead of threatening the
school districts with rules violations
well over a year into their
policies the state should have taken
those rules into account from the very
beginning to protect New Hampshire
students and to promote a partnership
between local districts and Families
unfortunately that's not what
happened in fact parents concerns with
masks causing barriers to learning were
ignored concerns with masks causing
children to have behavioral and mental
health issues were
ignored parents just wanting their
healthy children to be able to breathe
freely were
ignored parents seeking an exemption for
autism or asthma were
ignored these mask mandates did not meet
the instructional needs of each
individual student or promote a school
environment that was conducive to
learning the truth is that fear won
during
covid and students and science
lost while school boards dealt with
significant blowback for their mask
mandates that must be
corrected decisions about mask mandates
are best left to experts at the state
level where emotions can be tempered
with scientific facts and a proper risk
benefit analysis can be
done this is not a big government
approach like the veto message says
this is government taking responsibility
for public health and not forcing the
decision making onto local school boards
that are not equipped to make those
decisions I'd be willing to bet that
many school boards never want to be
faced with that responsibility
again The veto message states that big
government is never the solution and
neither is a one siiz fits-all
approach but the state takes this exact
approach with another medical
intervention required to attend
school the vaccine
schedule should we allow school boards
to create vaccine
policy would it be acceptable for
Manchester to say thank you for
providing guidance but we will only
require these two vaccines to attend
school or for Hollis to say we we aren't
going to require any vaccines at all
local
control just as one District could say
we will mandate masks every flu season
and another that leaves it to parent
choice the problem is none of that
promotes fair and Equitable access to
education as stated in the veto message
one of the state's foremost
responsibilities is to know the limits
of of its power I
agree but it is also our responsibility
to protect the individual from being
infringed upon by any level of
government I urge you to support both
students and school boards by pressing
the green button to override this veto
thank
you the state constitution requires a
roll call a two-thirds vote is required
to override a veto this will be a roll
[Music]
clear this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative luno for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this bill is bad Public Health policy
and if I voted no on this bill before
then wouldn't I press the red button now
to prevent this bill from becoming law
thank you Mr Speaker chair recognize
representative Noble for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that decisions about
Mas mandates are best left to experts at
the state if I know that if this were to
become law it would protect School
boards from being put in the middle of
contentious mask
debates and finally if I know that we
can never let this happen to New
Hampshire students again what I now
veto this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor of having the bill become law
you will press the green button if you
opposed and wish to sustain the
governor's veto you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
well president had an opportunity to
vote 160 voting a 172 voting a the
sustained house will attend to the
governor's veto message on House Bill
1187 relative to prohibiting the lease
agreements of equipment for building or
facility
improvements chair recognizes
representative
power thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of overriding the veto and House
Bill 1187 becoming law this is a common
sense bill that had wide bipartisan
support in both the house and the other
chamber this bill was unanimously
recommended ought to pass as amended 20
to Z by the municipal and County
government committee it passed the house
on a Voice vote on the consent calendar
and then the Senate amendment was
concurred by the house also by a Voice
vote this bill modifies RSA
337e titled lease agreements of
equipment pertaining to lease purchase
agreements with a non-appropriation
clause also called an escape Clause so
that equipment leased under this RSA do
not contain permanently installed
equipment nor facility improvements or
building Renovations that become
fixtures understand the legislative
intent of this RS A is for equipment
such as a vehicle like a fire Tru
ambulance or police cruiser or portable
equipment such as a back ho a chipper or
a copy machine these items are not
deeply installed and they do not become
fixtures and importantly if the Escape
Clause is invoked to end the lease all
of these items are easily
returned Mr Speaker this bill is needed
because political subdivisions across
the state are misusing lease purchase
agreements with Escape Clauses for
equipment under RSA
337e in order to fund significant
facility improvements and building
Renovations around deeply installed
equipment such as boilers windows and
led Li them light ing that all become
fixtures in one case a
20year
25.2 million lease with an escape Clause
is being used for quote overdue repairs
in maintenance to facilities end quote
unfortunately this lease is costing
taxpayers an estimated $6.5 million more
than if a bond was used since interest
rates for lease purchase agreements with
Escape Clauses are always significantly
higher than for bonds due to the
flexibility to escape the lease
additionally escape from this type of a
lease for items that become fixtures is
not economically feasible the act of
uninstalling removing replacing and
reinstalling Capital items is both
impractical and cost
prohibitive furthermore it goes without
saying that a least building renovation
or addition cannot be realistically
returned therefore the city town or
school district is essentially locked
into the lease and taxpayers pay for the
flexibility of an escape Clause that
they cannot use finally The veto message
clearly reveals s that this bill as well
as current rsas are unfortunately
misunderstood specifically the claims
that this bill would effectively
prohibit the use of Municipal leases to
acquire fixtures and that leases must be
secured more frequently than bonding
opportunities permit are both faulty and
incorrect let me be very clear House
Bill
1187 absolutely
does not prohibit lease agreements
instead it Narrows the scope of lease
purchase agreements covered by RSA
337e and it also clarifies importantly
what is
equipment importantly both leases under
both leases under RSA 32 as well as
energy performance Contracting which
falls under
22i which the these types of leases
guarantee that savings produced by an
energy product project will be
sufficient to finance the full cost of
the project these are both still
supported and are unaffected under this
bill despite last minute erroneous
claims by some
lobbyists notably both leases and bonds
have the same timeline and equal number
of annual
opportunities as both are proposed osed
as part of the annual budget and annual
meeting process to conclude House Bill
1187 is a common sense bill that adjusts
the scope of lease purchase agreements
with an escape Clause this bill ensures
that leases under RSA 37
337e do not contain permanently
installed equipment that become fixtures
nor building Renovations which makes the
lease both impractical to escape and
unnecessarily expensive to
taxpayers importantly under this bill
lease purchase agreements and energy
performance Contracting do remain
funding options for all political
subdivisions under RSA 32 and 21i at a
lower cost to taxpayers which was
confirmed by the New Hampshire Municipal
Association in the Senate hearings
lastly Mr Mr Speaker by overriding The
veto we are putting the needs of every
Granite stator who is overpaying in
property taxes for these types of leases
ahead of the wants of lobbyists this
bill is a positive and needed statutory
update for our constituents while
ensuring that Leasing and energy
companies can make a fair but not
excessive profit for these reason
reasons I urge my fellow colleagues to
uphold the position of the house to
support House Bill 1187 becoming law and
vote Yes to override The veto by pushing
the green button thank you Mr
Speaker the state constitution requires
a roll call a two-thirds vote is
required to override a veto this will be
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Len turot for
inquiry turkot waves off if you're in
favor of the bill becoming law you will
press the green button if you oppose and
wish to sustain the governor's veto you
will press the red button voting
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 161 voting yay 170 voting aay got
Vito was the stand chair recognizes is
the
clerk thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
the committee on enroll bills has
examined and found correctly enrolled
the following titled House and Senate
bills Senate Bill 137 relative to Nano
Brewery licenses and beverage
manufacturers
licenses the house will attend to the
governor's veto message on House Bill
a
question a question before the house is
not withstanding of Governor's veto
shall House Bill 1 through2 become
law the state require the state
constitution requires a roll call of
two3 Voters required to override a veto
this will be a roll call vote members
you
this is a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that the Humane
Society and other animal welfare
organizations supported this bill
and still support this bill and if I
know that my constituent the governor
claimed that the reason that he vetoed
the bill was that it said anyone that
was in a nationally accredited Cairo
program chiropractor
program um instead of saying vet or
chiropractor but only vets and
chiropractors are admitted into
nationally accredited Chiropractic
programs and if I know that a human
being being and not even a child needs a
referral to see a chiropractor so why
would an
animal and if I know that especially
farm animals that carry heavy loads like
draft horses sustain injuries that
chiropractor service would be coste
efficient and quick to help relieve but
that getting a referral from a vet first
could be cost prohibitive in relieving
that animal's pain and if finally that I
know that this bill was unanimously
supported by both parties in the
committee both parties unanimous in this
chamber both parties in the committee
across the the wall and both parties on
the floor across the hall
unanimously and that I know both parties
members of both parties still support
this bill across the wall would I now
press the green button to override this
senseless veto
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor of having the bill become law you
will press the green button if you are
opposed and wish to sustain a Governor's
veto you will press the red button
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 179 voting a 152 voting nay
the household attendo Governor's veto
message on House Bill 1293 relative to
Turf chair recognizes representative
thank you uh thank you Mr
Speaker uh good morning everyone I've
been asked to to remind you that I I had
a career working at Dees and spent many
hours in the field working on water
quality issues and clean water is
extremely important to me as it is to
I and I'm working hard in the new fin
Lake Area also for similar issues of
nutrient
introduction from The Watershed into the
lake and how we're going to manage that
through best management
practices on the land use level this
bill though well-meaning does put the
cart before the horse it
ignores the state's Dees cyanobacteria
plan and its suggestion for the use of
the best management practices are the
current
law for managing golf courses and sod
farms in the Department of Agriculture
so phospherous and nitren are the two
blooms and drive cyanobacteria blooms as
well however turf fertilizer now
contains little Turf in the as as
defined in the law basically we're
talking about grass turf fertilizer
contains little or no phosphorus anymore
and is no longer likely a major
contributor of phosphorus to some
watersheds uh uh unlike what you may
hear according to Dees and the state
cyanobacteria plan the first thing that
we should do to address
nutrients going to cyanobacteria blooms
is to identify the source es of
phosphorus in the
Watershed each Watershed specifically
they're all
different common sources of these
nutrients phosphorous in particular are
Wastewater agricultural runoff septic
rain water foul organic matter the
leaves in your yard weathering of rocks
and historic sediments that are already
at the bottom of lakes that have been
there for decades so cyanobacteria is
natural and after all its growth is
enhanced by the introduction of these
nutrients but they can come from many
sources so a recent study from the
University of
Minnesota found that up to 60% of damage
to Urban
Lakes is caused by excess
nutrients that are produced by Leaf
litter or the leaves that are that are
in your yard if they're improperly
cleaned up or if they're not disposed of
properly they will break down and they
can contribute Foster to the
environment that's where you get up
that's where you have a brown River like
the Smith River and damur it's a brown
River that's from Leaf debris and
down in de's testimony to the
committee they state in their letter
excuse me for for reading this
Nationwide the industry has removed
Foster from most bags of fertilizers
sold at retail
Market forces have largely taken care of
this issue at the retail
level in their testimony Dees also
expressed concerns on the enforcement of
this bill because it has two portions
one that regulates both the
landowner and the small
businessman and then it also dictates
what can be sold at retail furthermore
Dees and its cyano bacteria plan has as
a second priority not the first priority
the second priority in the C bacteria
plan from Dees is the development of
local overlay plans to manage nutrients
translate that to your local land
use setting plans of its own for a
shed so according to Dees and this makes
uh perfect sense to me for my my uh
background working in the
field it's not possible if you take a
sample on the lake and Foster is
X you don't know where that Foster came
from you cannot say it came from
fertilizer or you can't say it came from
Leaf waste there's no way to identify at
the lake level where did phosphorus come
from and this little uh actual sampling
to show specific sources one of the
water bodies that was a driver of this
legislation Arlington Reservoir
there is no data little data the dees
has excuse me for identifying where the
phosphorus has come from that affects
there therefore regulating phosphorus at
the turf level is not going to guarantee
in any way
whatsoever that you're going to prevent
cyanobacteria
blooms the use of best management plans
specifically targeted to each Watershed
is the better solution through education
as the is the tail end of the bill talks
about
education this week one of our my fellow
Representatives received a letter from a
lawn fertilization company that states
they would have a significant impact on
their work and they also state that they
have not been using fertilizer that
contains phosphorus since
2013 and most of what they do most of
the work they do is with nitrogen
for an annual fertilization of your lawn
Foster generally is only used for new
Lawns or for
lawn so to summarize that if that made
reducing phosphorus through controlling
fertilizer at the home
level has an
unknown and very likely minimal impact
on the phosphorus that ends up in your
ponds Dees
recommends that in three places the in
their fosterers fact sheet in their
testimony to the committee
and in the state's cyanobacteria plan
the dees
recommends using best management plans
to make sure that you protect your water
bodies from the in influx of nutrients
excuse
me having spoken
with the assistant commissioner Dees the
Commissioner of Agriculture the lead de
person for
cyanobacteria and with a person in
agriculture who manages pesticides and
fertilizers this week There's complete
agreement among
them that all of the regulatory
requirements in this bill are
unenforceable and if you were to have
read it closely you would notice that
that's the case they are only they're
only enforceable after the fact did you
apply too much fertilizer and the
homeowner says no but the neighbor says
oh I know he did and then the inspector
comes and says
this was two weeks ago there's nothing I
can do so there's a number of things in
this bill that are unenforceable in that
way
so I thought I'd add a little piece on
this at the very end this is not if you
this is not a vote against the
environment if you're concerned about
the perception of how you might vote on
this this is truly a vote for the
environment because in the long run
money will be more wisely spent on
controlling these
nutrients as they head towards your
surface water in best management
practices and by local
communities understanding exactly what
their Watershed is composed of do you
have a cold deep lake with a few
Cottages around it do you have a shallow
warm lake with three or four layers of
of cottages around it which is a
completely different thing I have gone
over what I was supposed to say and I'm
sure I'm over my 3 minute limit so I
enourage you to vote red and to uphold
the governor's veto thank you chair
bordis thank you Mr Speaker I am
actually a co-sponsor of this bill and I
am asking everybody in the house to
sustain the governor's veto house bill
1293 will make it against the law for an
individual to apply any fertilizer on
their
lawn during or before a predicted
rainfall when the ground is Frozen when
the grass is actively growing within 25
ft of a storm drain or deposited where
could enter a storm
drain um within 25 ft of river Rivers
streams Creeks Brooks reservoirs ponds
lakes and so forth despite these
extremely restrict restrictive rules for
The Lawns uh of
individuals sad farms and golf courses
are exempt from this so for example the
uh Laconia Country Club which is right
on porus Bay or a block away from porus
Bay would not have these restrictions
enforced on it I live right on porus Bay
on Lake wiip pasak we have a major cob
bacteria issue there but this bill will
not help this is a toothless bill it
will not be enforced um the only time
this will be enforced is if a neighbor
complains Joe next door he over
fertilizes his lawn it's toothless there
is no way to enforce this bill the
Department of Agriculture would only
cons uh conduct inspections based on a
complaint so if nobody complains how do
we enforce this bill there are no
penalties for the violation of this
law if there's no penalties what is the
use of having a
law if the veto is overturned an
individual in the state who is simply
trying to get grass to grow on their
yard will likely be in some shape or
form in violation of this bill um as far
again there's really no enforcement
mechanism but I don't want to be in
violation of anything I don't use
fertilizer but many people do this bill
would sail through in a state like
Massachusetts we are not Massachusetts
we are the live free a die State as the
governor stated in his veto me message
if the intent of this legis of the
legislature was to reduce the impact of
these fertilizers in New Hampshire water
bodies that I encourage future
legislation to be more targeted towards
Lakes streams and other environmentally
sensitive
areas as well as include practic
practical mechanisms for enforcement
again if this bill can't be enforced
there's no use in it I urge everybody
here to sustain the governor's veto on
this Bill thank you you recognize
representer
kraton thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues I rise in support of
overriding the governor's veto for HB
1293 this bill was closely considered in
committee and in fact the letter
referenced earlier by my colleague uh
was in due consideration and the bill
was substantially amended with close
cooperation with Dees Department of
Agriculture and the Farm Bureau based on
the input from that
letter upon further review the committee
approved the bill 20 to nothing it
passed this body it also passed the ways
and means 20 to nothing and it passed on
the other side of the wall four to
nothing this bill will help improve and
sustain the quality of water of water in
the
state it is a good bill that protects
our water and I support an override of
the governor's veto please press green
Speaker question before the house is
notwithstanding the governor's Vos house
bill 1293 become law the state
constitution requires a roll call two3
vot is required to override a veto this
will be a roll call vote members take
your
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Harley Buller
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill relies on vague
and confusing language and definitions
and if I also know that this bill is
unenforceable and lastly if I know that
phosphorus has been removed from
commercial fertilizer when I now not
press the red button and sustain the
you this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor of having the bill become law
you will press the green button if
you're opposed and wish to sustain the
governor's vetle you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 232 voting aay 99 voting aay
house will attend to the governor's veto
message on House Bill 1415 relative to
liability chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker members of the
house I rise today to urge the members
to act together to overturn the
governor's veto of House Bill
1415 this bill holds P facilities
accountable for proper decontamination
and
cleanup no amount of these forever
chemicals is
acceptable as elected officials we have
a duty to protect our clean
water past contamination is a proven
threat and we must ensure those
responsible for pollution not the
taxpayers bear the cost of cleanup with
32 years in the district I've seen the
impact of industrial contamination
firsthand as a community paramedic I've
treated people at the chemfab site long
before San Cobain ever took over in fact
I've witnessed marac medals and New
Hampshire plating become super fun sites
in our town and enough is
enough I've been on the resources
committee and the Commerce Committee so
I've seen both sides of these bills the
regulatory side and the cleanup side I
also serve on the long-term Drinking
Water Commission and those colleagues
agree also that this is a sensible
override it's not a partisan issue it's
a healthare issue clean water is a good
thing it's about protecting our families
from this long-term health risk the
resources committee passed this on a
Voice vote or passed it 20 to nothing
and the house passed it on consent on a
Voice vote so now it's time we get
together override the governor's veto
Safeguard our water let's do what's
right for the people of New Hampshire
please press the green button today and
override this veto thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognized sentive Nancy
Murphy
thank you Mr
Speaker HB
1415 addresses the needs to hold P
accountable PS polluters accountable for
the immense costs they create by
contaminating New Hampshire's air water
and
soil in marac alone we have spent
millions of dollars to remove a
company's pest from our drinking
water that this financial burden has
been placed upon taxpayers who are
already bearing the health CL costs is
absolutely unjust and it should be
illegal on behalf of the communities we
represent we have the power and
responsibility right now to do the right
thing and write this
wrong hb1 1415 forces polluters to pay
for their own cleanup and will also
serve as a deterrent for other pfast
polluters making them think twice about
how they handle these toxic
chemicals even low levels of residual
contamination on equipment piping and
structures can contribute to soil and
groundwater contamination and potential
human
exposure we must Empower de to hold
polluters accountable to Core Federal
requirements applicable to hazardous
waste generating
facilities ensuring that past facilities
that have adversely impacted our water
sources be promptly decontaminated upon
closure and cease posing a threat of
harm this bill is all about protecting
the health of granite Staters
safeguarding our natural resources and
making polluters to pay to clean up
their own mess I urge you to press the
green button and vote Yes to overturn
the Governor's
veto question before the house is not
withstanding the governor's veto so
House Bill 1415 become law state
constitution requires a roll call a
2third vote is required to override a
veto this will be a roll call vote
call
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Vil for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you m thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this is a simple
bill that asks polluters to pay for
toxins they leave in the
environment and if I also know that the
bill was unanimous out of committee that
the house voted unanimously on consent
calendar and then it went unanimously
out of committee on the other side of
calendar and if I also know that there
is there was no testimony against this
bill in the hearings would I now vote
Yes to override The veto by pushing the
green
button this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor of having the bill
become law you will press the green
button if you are opposed and wish to
sustain the government as veto you will
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
represent
Harvey you can't push it I need thumbs
down all members present had an
opportunity to vote H will tend to stay
the
vote 289 voting a 38 house will be in
order
overridden hous attend to the governor's
1581 1581 relative to cultivation
locations for alternative treatment
Lon thank you Mr Speaker friends we
sadly find ourselves near the end of our
time together I appreciate the
relationships we built the good laws we
have passed in the process we have the
opportunity now to do one more good
thing we can rescue a good bill House
Bill 1581 would allow cultivate allow
alternative treatment centers to operate
additional cultivation centers including
green houses it had a thorough
discussion in health and human services
and it passed on the consent calendar
the governor vetoed this bill stating
and I quote the legislation provides
scant detail regarding safety security
and location requirements these details
are necessary to ensure appropriate
controls on a regulated substance so the
good news is that's all already in
administrative rules current law allows
multiple dispensing locations and this
bill Echoes the same language to enable
multiple cultivation locations both
refer to the rule making authorization
that's already there but there is one
other section for the dispensing
locations so I made sure that that
didn't matter I went through all 65
pages of administrative rules dealing
with safety security and location not
once did it site that extra little bit
for the extra dispensing locations so
quite frankly we don't need anything
more than what was ped it was a
beautifully written elegant bill that
added only the language we needed we
already have safety security and
location and this requires the
municipality and the department to meet
with stakeholders and make sure they
listen to the concerns on location so
while I appreciate the fact that the
governor is very concerned to make sure
that we're doing it right we already are
thank you to the sponsors for not adding
extra words and I ask everybody to vote
green to override The
veto question before the house is
notwithstanding the governor's veto
should House Bill 1581 become law state
constitution requires a roll call a
2third vote is required to override a
veto this is a roll call vote members
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Lon for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the governor is Con concerned about
details regarding safety security and
location requirements and if I know that
these details are already address
addressed in existing law and
administrative rules and if I know that
I wouldn't have given this Pi if so many
people hadn't have walked out would I
button this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor of having the bill
become law you will press the green
button if you oppos and wish to sustain
the governor's veto you'll press the red
button voting station are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
divine all members president had an
opportunity to vote also ATT the state
vote 270 voting a 55 voting a Governor's
overridden house will attend to the
governor's veto message on House Bill
1622 FN relative to administrative rul
making license renewals by the Office
Professional lure and certific vacation
question before the house is not
withstanding the governor's veto shall
House Bill 1622 FN become law state
constitution requires a roll call a
two-thirds vote is required to override
a veto this is going to be a roll call
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor of the bill becoming law you will
press the green button if you opposed
and wish to sustain the governor's veto
you will press the red button voting
[Music]
represent
Maier all members presentent and an
opportunity to vote house will attain
vote 318 voting yay 11 voting nay
I'm asking that everyone sit in their
seats we're done with the bills but we
do have some things that are going to
happen so please sit in your seats for
just a little bit the chair recognized a
member from Auburn represent osbor for a
session resolved that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
all are you ready for the question all
those in favor to say I let oppose nay
adopted this is
uh the last time the legislature will
meet before the new term begins in
December there are many of you who won't
be returning for the next term
maybe you chose not to run for
reelection or seek another
office whatever your case may be we want
to thank you for your service to the
communities in the state of New
Hampshire by serving in an historic
body and I'd like
to just read a few of these and please
no clapping Until the
End 20 more years of service Jeff goalie
Steve
schliff 18 years of service Andy Rulo
Mark mccon David bigford Pat long Jane
bullo 16 years of service Michael Bryan
14 years of service Lorie sanber Joe
Petri 12 years of service Bruce Tetro
Dave huitt Le metoi and Mel Meyer 11
years of service Mary Heath 10 years of
service Tracy Emer Jr H Amanda Balden
Susan Tran Michael Albert Cliff Newton
and Rebecca
McBeth can I have all of those that I
[Applause]
and now and now can we have everybody
that isn't coming back stand
up everybody that isn't coming back
stand
[Music]
[Applause]
up and now I want to thank and I think
we all need to give them a tremendous
Applause I want to thank the clerk staff
[Applause]
I've got to say
that they have
done an absolute tremendous job over the
last four years and especially the last
two years and I also want to thank the
staff of the general court the uh
majority office minority office the
speaker's office uh without them I can
guarantee you this body probably
wouldn't run properly so they deserve a
[Applause]
Applause and we also need to thank
committee
services and all the other staff people
in this building that make this place
work we have one of the smallest staffs
in the country and I can tell you that
these people do a tremendous amount of
work and I personally want to thank all
[Applause]
[Music]
chair recognizes a clerk for messages Mr
Speaker the Senate has voted to sustain
the governor's veto on the following
bills Senate Bill 63 Senate Bill 318
Senate Bill 501 Senate Bill 507 and
543 chair recognizes representative
announcement hey y'all Pizza free front
lawn
five different varieties we got cheese
pepperoni veggie Hawaiian Philly cheese
steak and then you get to vote for your
favorite one using instant runoff voting
also known as rank Choice voting and
then you get to watch it happen in front
of you be counted quick easy simple but
in any case no matter what you think no
the science technology and energy
committee will meet in executive session
one half hour after the conclusion of
this veto session in the Legislative
Office Building in rooms 302 and 304
thank
thank you Mr Speaker uh on October 15th
at 700 p.m the progressive caucus will
meet via Zoom please be on the lookout
for an email later today thank you J
Lon thank you Mr Speaker Dair
Representatives please meet over here as
soon as we're
out chair recognized Representative
Steven
Smith thank you Mr Speaker Republican
members and Republican candidates the
speaker invites you to a reception out
the front doors and across the street at
tandies where you enjoy a variety of
good food War stories commiserations and
most importantly have a beer or glass of
wine
there chair recognizes representative
Wilhelm Mr Speaker I move that your
remarks recognizing our long- serving
members and our hardworking staff be
printed in the permanent
journal without
objection chair recognizes the clerk
thank you Mr Speaker just a couple of
quick announcements your mailbox is in
the back some of which have not been
touched in over a year please please
clean them out because they will be
emptied uh after almost immediately
after the election because we have to
prepare for uh new folks and even if
you're reelected Your Position will
probably still move so please empty out
your mailboxes for non- returning
members uh if you had a locker please
see Tracy in my office upstairs uh to
return locks and/ or Keys uh Easy Pass
transponder and door cards um those can
be returned to the general court
administration office on the first floor
and lastly uh just as a a personal uh
thank you from me Mr Speaker to all of
the members uh last week um I was very
fortunate along with the Senate Clerk
and our teams to host the American
Society of legislative clerks and
secretaries annual professional
development seminar in
Manchester we had the highest attendance
we actually sold through two two of the
larger hotels in Manchester the Double
Tree and the true uh and we had
fantastic uh uh fantastic reception um
at the kuer Museum we had a fantastic
day up here at the state house um some
of you met uh the many clerks and
secretaries from around the country and
I just want to thank you for your
support uh it truly meant a lot thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
we have one unanimous consent
representative
McWilliams thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I Rise with both Joy
gratitude and humbleness to speak with
you briefly between me and pizza and
apparently free drinks if you're on that
side of the aisle so um I'll be
brief uh wrapping up my third term sixth
year I just wanted to do a brief
reflection and thank everyone who has uh
served with me for the past six years
it's been an honor um six years ago I
had just won a primary and I was sitting
up in the gallery on veto day so six
years ago veto day and Mary Stewart gues
who was my predecessor in marac 27 then
30 poster districting uh Mary Stewart
gues implored us as a body she said we
really need to find a way to compensate
legislators and we really need to make
sure that we are representative of a
cross-section of the state and I want to
say that we've done some work to to get
closer to that but there is more work to
do so to reiterate that she believed in
that I believe in that and it's
something that we're working on as a as
a team together we have fortunately
upgraded some some of our technology all
of you were able to sign in not today
but when we actually get paid mileage
you were able to sign in and press some
buttons and track your mileage we are so
much closer to getting a perdum while
you get your mileage you could get a pum
if we vote that through next year just a
thought um in terms of my journey as a
legislator uh the first year that I was
elected 2019 I was able to work across
the aisle with some Republican
colleagues to update our building code
and I'm really proud of that work we
also put through a child care business
study with some cross uh bipartisan work
and that child care business study later
turned into the special committee on
child care so we are building to address
some of the biggest issues in our state
when it comes to child care as a mom of
three one of whom is in preschool right
now Child Care is a huge issue and I
implore you to continue the work for
child care um next year it's really
important we've also been bonded
together uh we went through covid
together we did a road show legislature
we were in an ice arena and outdoor
Athletic Field a sports complex the UNH
parking lot in our cars uh and we also
modernized during that time I will tell
you that I was nursing as a nursing mom
and I was able to pump in some of those
locations and when we came back here as
a legislature we actually had a mamava
in the basement of the loob so I could
keep pumping so congratulations and Well
Done team well done we are
modernizing um
[Applause]
again we did the special committee on
child care and that's awesome I think we
need to keep pushing for that we also
did a special committee on housing with
some big wins this year so Pat
yourselves on the back for those
bipartisan wins on housing um I'm really
proud of modernizing a little bit of um
our parking reform for multif family I
think that will make a big difference
for developments and for those of you
who know about development real estate
development in existing Lots uh we can
now re-evaluate parking and there's real
opportunity for housing um I recently
lost my primary election for Senate but
that doesn't mean that I am done I am
incredibly proud of the work that we've
all done as elected officials and you
all know what it feels like to win or
lose an election so I feel for you I
feel with you I'm here I stand beside
you and I'm taking a sabatical for two
years my middle name is Joy I'll be back
it's been a joy and honor to serve with
you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
representative osban moves at the h
stand in recess for the purpose of
receiving messages after which business
is concluded the H shall stand adjourned
for the 2024 session are you ready for
the question question all those in favor
say I those oppose nay the eyes have it
the motion is adopted the house stands